residents of the island of java are used
to Tremors the movement of the Earth but
this earthquake which struck after lunch
was far more powerful
it brought down the walls of hundreds of
homes and businesses the roofs falling
in on those inside
[Music]
safety was sought in the open air
although many bore the scars of their
escape
the hospitals did not avoid it
the wards were damaged the complex
losing power so the emergency room was
moved Outdoors
thousands of people sought treatment in
beds and plastic mats that were arranged
outside but there weren't enough doctors
to help everyone
and many thousands will go without
treatment for the roads have been
blocked by landslides and people in more
isolated communities have been trapped
the governor said the death toll was
preliminary and he expects it to grow
there were 162 people killed
326 people injured most suffered a
broken bone or were injured because of
falling objects and incision wounds and
there were also around 13
784 evacuees as the evening turned to
night
those who were able dug into the rubble
trying to release those trapped
underneath
foreign
emergency has outgrown the car park yet
residents from the district continue to
arrive with staff forced to prioritize
their treatment
John Sparks Sky News